Bonjour... Aujourd'hui nous allons ensemble jouer..
MalaiseTv c'est pour toi !
Des fois, il faut que j'apprenne à juste continuer les essentiels
(en bafouillant) à savoir "Yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur Guts and glory" Voila.
Comma ça j'suis à l'abri de tout malaise, tout se passe bien.
On est sur Guts and Glory souvenez-vous c'est le jeu,
l’espèce de Happy Wheels en 3D hein,
et c'est aussi la vidéo avec la miniature la plus dégeulasse de youtube de ces 2 derniéres années.
Merci Lucas Hauchard, c'est pour vous hein,
Il y a eu des nouveaux levels comme vous pouvez les voir ici présent
Donc on va s’empresser de les faire, on commence avec Homewrecker
Ouuuuuuuuuuh....
Ceci est un nouveau personnage
LA FAMILLE YANG ?!
Mais moi je veux prendre la famille Yang !!
"Spam sa souris"
Pourquoi elle est pas valable ? Putain... voilà Raciste de Merde va !
Bon bah on prend Earl, on prend le russekov, avec.. avec son beau shot gun dans le coffre, on est parés mec!
Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaah...
On est parés à.. NAAN! J'ai perdu la cagotte,
pas la cagotte! C'est bon j'ai la batte de baseball.. NAN! Pas la batte de baseball!
On est ti-par, on part sur du willy, sur du cassage de glace
Pour le moment c'est tranquille. Ah m*rde, c'est pas là, c'est pas là, c'est pas là!
Shit. *Bruitage "boing"*
Ça va tu résistes, t'es un bonhomme. T'es un p'tit peu en caoutchouc, hein,
on va pas t'mytho, on t'a grillé. AH ! Y a les arbalètes qui
m'tirent dessus ! Est-ce que c'est normal ? Noon..
On y va yolo, backflip. Il y a l'arbalète
Ah p*tain, faut qu'on esquive l'arbalète mec. AAAH !
AAAH ! MAIS RESTE PAS IMMOBILE !
Yeee..
Alors tu saignes de l'*nus, tu feras attention.
Toujours pas d'famille Yang mais p*tain ! Quand est-ce qu'on va pouvoir la prendre ?! Oulala..
C'est quoi ces trucs qui roulent ? C'est pas des bombes ça à tout hasard?
Nan c'est des pastèques. Ça va tout
s'passe bien. OUAAAAAH!
*Cri de chèvre*
Ah ca m'a fait peur pour de vrai
AAAAAH c'est humiliant de faire des cris comme (ne finit pas sa phrase)
je sais pas ce qu'il me prend en ce moment, je crie pour rien
c'est incroyable
Allez cette fois on esquive, on va, on va contourner
tu vois on va passer assez loin du canon
ALLEZ P*TAIN MEC, chez quel concessionnaire tu as acheter ce quad mec
j'ai jamais vu un quad aussi peu maniable
Allez boloss, allez boloss AAAH
t'es pas un boloss pardon
d'ailleurs tu ferais attention tu saignes de l'intestin maintenant
Ah ... mais, mais téma, mais regarde le quad
Tu l'essayes, tu l'achètes pas.
P*tain ...
Let's ... do this fucking shit !
Comme dirait ma prof d'anglais.
Aller, on y va ! C'est ... GAGNÉ !
À non c'est pas fini.
YOLO !
Oh p*tain mais en plein dedans Quoi !
Attends comment faire ?
J'pense qu'il faut arriver pleine balle
Comme ça :
Nan, vraiment pas !
En faite il faut arriver comme ça je pense :
Llllaa !
Et pas là !
Si quelqu'un y croit : il lève la main.
OOOOHHHHH  *rire*
TIENS !
Tiens celui qu'la personne n'a levé la main bah DANS TON C*L !
Y avait une PS4 à gagner mon pote !
*Bam !*
*Argh*
Main non nique ta mère !
Mais non, mais à ce moment là on arrète tout et on fait une vidéos où on joue au Kapla quoi !
En plus, j'ai acheté un 2ème pot de fleur donc j'en ai 4 au lieu de 2. On peut faire des constructions de ouf.
Lourd ou pas ?
Alors level suivant, toujours avec Earl !
600 m l'objectif mon gars !
Mais c'est quoi ça, c'est un marathon de paris c'qu'on fait là ?
Ah c'est vrai qu'ça fait des ...
Oooohhhhh, c'est beau !
Oh, c'est super beau c'que vous faites les gars !
C'est super beau !
*musique Peter Pan* tu t'envole , tu t'envole , tu t'envole
ah oui par contre la chute est moins belle
je pense qu'en  passant par le déjà on a plus de chance d'y arriver
*stress*
Adieu !
*rire*
laissez moi auprès de ce caillou me reposer en paix
vous n'avez donc aucune pitié ?
donc ça c'est un level de difficulté moyenne et là on passe sur du Hard ;c'est parfait
Toujours avec Earl, ben aller tu sais quoi moi j'ai toujours préféré le vélo. Voilà
Ce sera bien mieux que le gars avec son quad pourri là.
A vélo c'est bien plus maniable.
D'accord ;_; Et ben on va prendre Earl j'ai compris, on va prendre Earl et son quad !
Let's do this sh**
Parfait
On va y arriver tout est une question de...de Timing
La on arrête d’accélérer
Du coup on passe le truc ok
Il faut ralentir la
La , il faut accélérer avant que le...
Mais magnifique magnifique
Parfait Parfait , allez on recule comme ça on a esquivé la scie
Mais comment je passe la avec un quad
YOLOO BITCH !!!
M'en bat les cou***es j'peux encore conduire
J'ai une, j'ai une, appuie sur la pédale
Au p*tain c'est beau.
J'y arriverai.
J'y arriverai, vous ne m'aurez PAS!!
Ooohhhhh!!!
Oh oui!
Je viens de vous passer, je m'en bat les cou***es!!
*musique épique*
Excellent, alors...
*rires*
J'ai jamais changer de level aussi vite.
'Hard Wood', fait moi rêver
Rater.
'Surpris mother fu**er!'
Whaaaa!
Le prochain check point il est à 200m mon gars!
Aaahhhh!!
C'est bon, c'est bon,  c'est bon.
Oh la chance qu'on a eu c'est incroyable!
Oh oui!!
Passionnant ce jeu, hein?
Ah m*rde!
Voila c'était la vanne de trop.
Mais non! Hey je vous jure qu'il tourne a droite tout seul, non je vous promets.
De tout façon j'ai vue dés le début son bras il est né il étais un petit peu affaisser la du coté droit, donc euh..
Il a moins la patate pour tenir le guidon.
MalaiseTv, je te régale aujourd'hui!
*rires*
Ouais ça me pète les cou***es  on arrête les conneries la.
*musique épique*
Et bim le check point!!
M'en bat les cou***es de ton arme, je fais une figure stylée!
Merci ma petite chauve-souris!
Tu peux t'en aller.
On t'aime.
Les tronc d'arbre, les tronc d'arbre mais qui ce fait encore avoir par les tronc d'arbre sans déconner?
P*tain!
*rires*
P*tain les gars la ça devient hardcore du nord, mais vraiment quoi!
Hardcore Henry le film un peu pourrie filmer a la première personne.
Bah je vous le dis parce que j'ai commencer a le regarder et c'étais vraiment de la m*rde!
Aller, on y va! On y va! On y va!
Il passe maintenant, aller on peux y aller!
OUIIIIII P*tain!!!
Me dit pas qu'on va finir un niveau en difficulté hard!
Non!
Non ce n'est pas possible, j'y crois pas!
Il va y avoir une mine, un truc...
Merci a tous!
Et bah voila les gens c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur Guts and glory!
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plu !
J'adore ce petit jeu, je le trouve très sympa !
Euh les levels par contre il faut un niveau de skill euh..
Plus proche du Mickalow que du Squeezie quoi, sur l'échelle du skill.
Ce qui serait drôle en vrai je trouve: Ce serait de pouvoir faire des cours comme ça en multi !
Ce serais FANTASTIQUE!
Tu démarres cote-à-cote avec tes potes et t'envoie un se prendre une scie t'explose de rire avant la fin.
Tous ce qu'on aime !
On se retrouve très vite pour une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regarder potez vous bien !
Ciao tout le monde
Je suis batman.
<<Musique d'outro>>